pues como bien decía es una segunda
cumbre que como tantas otras cumbres
ambientales ha sufrido retrasos por la
pandemia de kobe 19 se tendría que haber
celebrado en 2020 pero estamos en 2022
aquí en lisboa celebrando esta
conferencia es una conferencia que
recibirá unas 7000 participantes entre
ellos unos 40 líderes de jefes de estado
y de gobierno entre muchos otros
participantes de la sociedad civil de
empresas privadas en fin todos los
actores
esenciales para que la financiación para
la protección del océano sea viable por
qué es tan importante esta conferencia
aunque el océano es uno de los recursos
que tenemos en el planeta que menos
atención al que menos atención prestamos
realmente es el más importante para
nuestro clima es regular el agua regula
los patrones de clima del planeta y
además de emitir el 50 por ciento del
oxígeno que respiramos es decir es el
verdadero pulmón del planeta además
absorbe un cuarto de las emisiones
o dos que emitimos los humanos y el 90%
del exceso de calor que emiten el resto
de gases de efecto invernadero como el
metano o muchos otros de los gases que
emitimos mil millones de personas
alrededor del mundo dependen
directamente de los recursos que salen
del océano y como tú bien decías raúl el
objetivo de esta cumbre es de esta
conferencia es poner soluciones
concretas para esas propuestas y esos
compromisos que se habían a los que se
habían llegado durante la cumbre de 2017
durante esta década de restauración de
ecosistemas de la onu y de los océanos
también se pretenden abordar varios
temas en concreto uno la contaminación
por plásticos quieren llegar a un
acuerdo global que se ha venido
trabajando durante varios meses para
poder limitar esa contaminación plástica
y 2
poder también llegar a
a proteger el 30 de los océanos antes de
2030 un anuncio que ya hizo colombia
como el único país del hemisferio oeste
en lograrlo